r merci beaucoup d'être avec nous ce
matin vous êtes bien sûr le président de
cette région grand est
on est ensemble pendant une heure pour
une interview en partenariat avec
l'alsace les dernières nouvelles
d'alsace
l'est républicain le républicain lorrain
est faux je m'attends il ya beaucoup de
régions de journaux dans la région grand
est à mes côtés pour cette interview
philippe rivet bonjour philippe oui
merci montre avec nos journalistes à
l'est républicain et emmanuel de la et
bonjour emmanuel journaliste à l'alsace
on parlera avec vous bien sûr je m'en
tenir des dossiers régionaux dans
quelques instants d'économie des
transports on parlera des régionales
mais d'abord évidemment on va vous
interroger sur ces crises sanitaires
vous avez entendu jean castex ir1 pas de
confinement pas de durcissement du
couvre-feu pas de limitation des
déplacements entre les régions est ce
que l'exécutif a raison de miser sur la
responsabilité les français jean castex
déjà bonjour et merci pour cet invité
sur matinale jean castex et fière a fait
beaucoup de pédagogie a émis beaucoup de
chiffres j'espère que les français
pourront s'y retrouver
c'est vrai que là besoin de pédagogie de
comprendre aujourd'hui quelle est la
stratégie quel est le sens donné un
petit peu aux mesures prises au niveau
national de manière à ce que nous
puissions les décliner le mieux possible
au niveau lequel pourquoi je dis ça
parce que et nous y reviendront
peut-être pendant cette heure je sors
quand même une colère naître chez les
français au delà d'une frustration là de
difficultés psychologiques que l'on
connaît petit à petit ces deux une
colère et il faut y faire extrêmement
attention être vigilant donc les
situation sanitaire nécessite
aujourd'hui une attention je crois que
le gouvernement est mobilisé sur ce
sujet pour autant à l'échelle régionale
qui est mon échelle je m'interroge sur
certaines situations celle de la moselle
par exemple aujourd'hui où on voit quand
même des chiffres inquiétants on est
plus de 400 cas pour 100000 habitants
il faut essayer de comprendre de
décrypter c'est ce que nous tentons de
faire localement avec nos outils en lien
avec la préfecture avec les autorités
sanitaires
mais il ya un questionnement
effectivement sur la moselle des mesures
peut-être spécifiques à prendre et ça
rejoint une position qui est la mienne
qui est celle des acteurs losio
pacifique jantes rs que ça veut dire que
vous êtes favorable à deir confinement
localiser si vous m'aviez dit c'est fini
un fusible
vous aurez déjà répondu je vais vous
dire justement il faut c'est ce que nous
revendiquons que éventuellement à
l'échelle d'une région à l'échelle d'un
département nous puissions avoir des
mesures particulières quand elle
s'imposer quand est comprise moi
aujourd'hui les chiffres de la moselle
je ne les comprends pas je ne comprends
pas cette situation quand on voit et
quand on regarde les cartes précises que
nous avons mises en place grâce à notre
outil prédictif on voit effectivement
que c'est là que c'est naturellement
metz thionville qui est touché et
surtout l'ouest de la région l'ouest de
metz le long de la frontière avec la
marque et moselle je ne sais pas
pourquoi ces endroits brûle plus que
d'autres mais il ya peut-être des
situations et deuxième analyse c'est
surtout les jeunes 10 19 ans qui
augmente très fortement et avec moins de
tests qui ont été réalisés tout cela
doit nous interroger à prendre les
bonnes décisions en pratique est
peut-être plus de tests dans cette
tranche d'âge
avant de prendre des décisions philippe
qui effectivement nécessiterait
peut-être localement un confinement ou
un renforcement de mesures très
localisés mais si ça ne tenait qu'à vous
jean rottner on re confinerait
aujourd'hui la moselle non non je ne
pense pas parce que les les tests n'ont
pas été réalisés en quantité suffisante
il ya encore trop d'incertitudes sur une
décision qui pèse aujourd'hui et si tout
le monde parle de se re confinement
potentiel je parlais de colère mais
cette colère elle couvre également parce
que depuis maintenant trop longtemps il
y a des contraintes qui s'exercent sur
les français qui parfois sont mal
comprises des situations qui valence
d'un avis à un contrat vie et c'est ça
ce qui est pénible
ce que je reproche parfois ou quand j'ai
pu effectivement monté volume comme on
dit c'est parce que il y avait des
mesures qui venaient se contredire d'une
semaine à l'autre des suspects et deux
premières régions finalement c'est le
président de la république à deux
reprises avant - qui publiquement dit il
faut accélérer qui aujourd'hui prend les
choses en main tous les lundis il
préside non pas un conseil de sécurité
sanitaire mais une réunion qui vise à
accélérer la vaccination c'est qu'il ya
bien un sujet c'est quelle époque il y
avait bien un sujet je vous le rappelle
nous étions à 5 ans le deuxième prêt le
costa rica 500 personnes vaccinées en
france
là on nous disait que tout allait pour
le mieux là où il ne fallait pas avoir
de centres de vaccination deux semaines
après il ya des centres de vaccination à
rendre à l'est des vaccins et je m'en
tenais à vous avez parlé des chiffres
effectivement ils sont préoccupants
est-ce qu'on a une notion de la
circulation des variants en particulier
le variant anglais dans le conteste
ils commencent visiblement à être un
petit peu plus fort dans les métropoles
chez nous au niveau régional metz nancy
strasbourg c'est normal ce sont des
lieux de brassage maintenant pour vous
dire à quel pourcentage par rapport aux
au virus habituel je n'ai pas su il ya
eu un séquençage la semaine dernière la
rs ne vous a pas je ne sais pas alors
alors qui précédemment dans cette
émission catherine trautmann appelé à un
assouplissement des mesures sanitaires
dans le monde de la culture est ce que
vous voulez suivre sur ce terrain est ce
que vous auriez favre a par exemple à la
réouverture du cinéma des musées d'un
certain nombre de lieux culturels ou pas
je suis éventuellement favorable qui
visiblement risque d'arriver c'est des
expérimentations possible dans des lieux
de culture un accompagnement on avait vu
militer aussi beaucoup pour les tests
salivaires
j'ai entendu que en tout cas dans les
milieux scolaires c'est peut-être un
test qui est développé dans le milieu
culturel
là où il ya une concentration pendant
par exemple pendant une soirée je
trouverais que le test salivaire serait
aussi d'une utilité certaine plutôt que
de se faire gratter le fond d'unique
c'est pas très agréable bien poursuivre
effectivement les gens qui sont dans ces
lieux où il ya une forte concentration
je test salivaire je penserai d'une
victime d'une utilité extrêmement forte
pour redonner confiance justement
puisque vous parlez des milieux
scolaires un mot sur l'école il ya les
vacances qui débutent ce soir pour la
première zone
est ce que vous dites il faut profiter
de ces vacances pour fermer plus
longtemps les écoles ou pour vous ça n'a
pas d'impact et il faut maintenir les
écoles fermés uniquement pendant les
quinze jours de vacances scolaires vous
savez j'ai appris depuis le début de
cette crise a gardé beaucoup d'humilité
face à je pense que je ne suis ni
épidémiologistes ni à la tête de ce pays
je ne suis que président de région même
si j'ai une expérience personnelle et
professionnelle de deux médecins et je
crois que ces éléments là je n'en ai pas
tous les éléments entre les mains pour
répondre clairement à votre que si
compris concernant les lycées que vous
gérez en train président aujourd'hui on
a des girondins des difficultés aussi
pour voir des directives nationales qui
arrive on a vu tomber la semaine
dernière la nécessité aujourd'hui de
respecter une règle de deux mètres dans
les cantines c'est extrêmement compliqué
donc il faut qu'on s'adapte qu'on
invente qu'on trouve
de restauration différents pour nos
élèves parfois en dehors du lycée
pendant la période scolaire c'est pas
simple les problèmes de responsabilité
et problème de conséquence effectivement
des décisions que nous prenons donc on
essaie de faire preuve d'intelligence
d'agilité de réactivité
depuis le début de cette crise c'est ce
que nous faisons et vous dites la
décision est tombée
ça veut dire qu'encore une fois il ya
trop de bureaucratie parce que depuis le
début de cette crise c'est vraiment à
l'expression de beaucoup d'élus locaux
et pas simplement de ceux qu'on appelle
les barons à la tête des régions
c'est effectivement cette verticalité
cette décision non concertée
alors que nous sommes tous embarqués
dans la même dans la nouvelle r6 qu'on
peut le dire il faut que ce pays sorte
le plus rapidement possible de la
situation dans laquelle il se trouve et
je crois que l'état ne perdent jamais
rien à s'appuyer sur ces collectivités
au contraire il gagne en agilité et son
conseil que l'état ne fait toujours pas
confiance aux connectivités vous pensez
que les relations s'améliorent non les
relations s'améliorent pas c'est
toujours très verticale il y à une un
gouvernement une administration
hypertrophié et des collectivités qui
sont là mais qui ne doit pas être qu'ils
ne doivent pas être non plus uniquement
dans la revendication qui doivent être
des apporteurs de solutions mais ça sera
mieux avec jean qu'avec jean castex qui
se dit apte l'homme des territoires qui
se voulait être l'homme du dialogue avec
les élus locaux rien n'a changé
rien n'est changé je veux dire que je
préférais même le dialogue
du précédent premier ministre que le
dialogue du premier ministre actuel
c'est encore ces différents différentes
c'est différent effectivement jean
castex d'y être l'homme des territoires
mais dans les faits la confiance et pas
forcément là où on est mis devant le
fait accompli sur un certain nombre de
décisions et ce dialogue manque manque
cruellement
le grand est c'est une région
frontalière est ce qu'on pratique à 7s
pcr à l'entrée du territoire
est-ce qu'on en pratique peut-être pas
de trop et ne faudra-t-il pas mettre en
place des tests antigénique et des tests
salivaires je préfère moi que la
question soit celle là les tests pcr ont
une utilité sont fiables sont sensibles
sont validées scientifiquement
je crois qu'il faut qu'on développe
aujourd'hui les tests de masse beaucoup
plus acceptable par la population si on
veut que la politique de tests soient
réalisables
ça c'est important et vous parlez de
notre position frontalière moi
j'apprécie aussi la qualité du dialogue
que nous avons aujourd'hui avec nos amis
allemands quasi quotidiennes de trois
fois cette semaine nous avons mentionné
d'ailleurs impact similaire à 1000 mhz
et land de bade wurtemberg
enfin plusieurs land allemand d'ailleurs
tout à fait mais ça va au delà de ça
parce que la crise est forte et nous
sommes aujourd'hui plus concernés que
les allemands qui ont pour objectif 50
personnes contaminées pour cent mille
habitants
là haut nous on se situe sur un plafond
jean lui sur une courbe plate de 200-250
et donc il ya des différences et des
attitudes ya un dialogue et à berlin et
paris
il ya luxembourg tout cela nous amène
aujourd'hui avoir un dialogue
transfrontalier dont je me réjouis de la
qualité parce que il est intense
il est pas évident il ya franchement des
avis parfois qui divergent
et au bout de nos réunions on arrive à
une forme de consensus qui avait pas
d'unanimité
no - de méthodes conjoint et ça ça a
beaucoup changé
on va parler précisément des vaccins
exactement je reviens cette campagne
vaccinale il ya à peu près un mois jean
rottner vous parliez à ce sujet d'un
scandale d'état en critiquant en gros le
la lenteur du démarrage
qu'en est il aujourd'hui est-ce que vous
restez sur cette critique où il ya du
mieux
j'ai dit tout à l'heure nous étions dans
une situation à la sortie de noël très
particulière première est une des
régions d'ailleurs dans lequel le
couvre-feu précoce avait été imposée
j'avais déjà des résultats plutôt
positifs puisque la courbe
plutôt que de progresser et est resté
plate n'étaient pas redescendus
mais surtout l'incompréhension de ce que
nous disait le gouvernement et qui nous
avons travaillé c'est vrai en proximité
depuis la mi-novembre réunion avec
olivier ferrand où il nous annonce un
certain nombre de vaccins fin décembre
un certain nombre de vaccinations
il nous dit il n'y aura pas de vacciner
de rome il y aura pas de centres de
vaccination pour changer d'avis début
janvier
rappelez vous ces paroles il faut aller
très doucement
progressivement il faut que les français
acceptent alors que sur le terrain on
l'entendait ce désir de vaccination
cette envie vraiment préfet seulement
les xenia les fasse changer pied depuis
et je crois que il donnait accès d'avoir
animé je donnais gouvernement
effectivement d'avoir accéléré au
président de la république tout
particulièrement d'avoir pris les choses
en main lui même et ça c'est fait
j'étais pas le seul mais c'est pas à
cause de mon coup de gueule que les
choses sont excellents mais je crois que
je fais partie effectivement de ce
qu'est moment donné on presser sur le
bouton allusion attention il ya danger
il ya danger parce que j'entendais les
mêmes signaux faibles que les signaux
j'avais entendu sur l'épisode des
masques et que là pour s'en sortir
économiquement il faudrait toujours
conservé des mesures aujourd'hui de
prévention de distanciation il faudra
toujours tester mais la vaccination
c'est la première arme pour sortir
économiquement notre pays de la
difficulté dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons pour que nos entreprises
repartent
moi j'ai des chefs d'entreprise qu'ils
envoient des mails des messages des
lettres en dix ans dis moi où je peux
acheter des vaccins il faut que je
vaccine méga pour qu'ils repartent pour
qu'il reparte à l'étranger parce que les
marchés sont là bas donc il faut
répondre aussi à sa liste avant avant
d'y répondu qu il faut la préparer
il faut anticiper et mon grand reproche
c'était le manque d'anticipation pour
qu'on soit clair aujourd'hui il ya plus
de scandale d'état
aujourd'hui les choses ont bougé ont
avancé et la difficulté c'est d'avoir
des vaccins c'est pas forcément liés au
gouvernement s'est dit plutôt aux
laboratoires
quand le ministre de la santé assure que
tous les français seraient vaccinés
d'ici la fin de l'été
ça vous paraît un objectif réaliste moi
je ne demande qu'à le croire vous avez
un doute
c'est lui nous apporter la preuve le
choix a été fait de passer par l'union
européenne pour l'achat des vaccins
c'était le bon choix quoique c'est une
fille j'ai enfin non non c'est une bonne
chose c'est une bonne chose pour qu'il
n'y ait pas de concurrence entre pays
européens
c'est peut-être la manière de négocier
il y aura peut-être fallu mettre un prix
un petit peu plus fort pour avoir des
mots de mick st peut-être un peu plus
rapidement en quantité supplémentaire
parce que il ya certes la négociation
européenne mais il a négocié sur
american ya eu négociation anglais ces
négociations
l'israélienne ils ont mis un peu plus
d'argent sur la table ils ont eu des
vaccins c'est l'offre et la demande
ils ont eu des vaccins plus rapidement
ils ont pu vacciner de manière beaucoup
plus conséquents population une question
de calendrier que l'europe ne s'est pas
pris trop tard
non si vous reprenez un peu l'histoire
il ya d'avoir quatre pays qui ont
négocié entre eux ensuite il rejoint où
il ya une demande européenne de faire
les choses conjointement ce a mis un peu
de temps comme souvent en europe
je pense que chaque pays a commencé au
bon moment ensuite il a négocié sur
européenne et peut-être on a cherché à
trop forcer sur les prix plutôt que de
chercher à avoir une quantité disponible
plus rapidement un mot peut-être d'une
décision qui concerne votre grande
région grand est c'est celle de ne pas
rouvrir les remontées mécaniques au mois
de février est ce que vous dites compte
tenu de la situation sanitaire c'est la
décision la plus raisonnable ou est ce
que vous dites y avait moyen de faire
autrement
déjà les vosges ont jamais été aussi
belle aussi blanche depuis tant d'années
donc c'est vrai que pour ceux qui aiment
la montagne c'est ça fait partie de ce
bonheur de nos territoires nos terroirs
c'est au-delà des remontées mécaniques
c'est toute une économie qui aujourd'hui
a été sabordée par par cette crise est
la décision du gouvernement est somme
toute une décision logique de la manière
on ne peut pas être incohérent sur une
ouverture des remontées mécaniques et
continuer à faire mes yeux de culture il
c'est vrai qu'il faut un peu de
cohérence est donc je peux la comprendre
mais c'est difficile parce que je
rappelle que une saison d'été se prépare
l'hiver en montagne et il faut qu
effectivement les investissements
réalisés
l'hiver puisse être rentabilisé pour que
la saison d'été se passe le mieux
possible pour les professionnels de du
tourisme et des loisirs
donc ça va être compliqué je vais très
vite ce n'est pas seulement la saison
les deux sont liés une bonne saison
d'être
versé la capacité d'investir pour une
bonne saison d'été donc il faut être
vigilant là aussi savoir les accompagner
nous ne sommes pas au bout du dispositif
que nous devons encore inventé pour
accompagner ces professionnels du
tourisme
ces professionnels de la montagne
professionnels de la restauration
il y a encore du travail pour nous il ya
encore des chantiers à ouvrir parce que
il ya des trous dans la raquette
jean regret le rappelait tout à l'heure
il ya des situations personnelles juste
dramatique quand il ya des suicides de
deux patrons de bars ou des restaurants
parce qu'ils ne voient pas le lendemain
on est dans ce drame humain qui est en
train de se jouer
et notre responsabilité de femmes et
d'hommes publics politique c'est
d'arriver à tirer la ficelle pour
arriver à la pelote et pour sauver cette
économie de proximité cette économie de
nos territoires ces toutes petites
économies mais qui tellement nécessaire
est tellement utile comment jean rottner
comme maire c'est peut-être encore avec
des moyens financiers encore avec de
l'ingénierie on est encore en train de
négocier au à l'heure où nous parlons
avec le monde bancaire pour sauver des
deux pays cette économie de la région
qui est extrêmement forte
on risque d'avoir des drames avec deux
des fleurons franchement des tenues à
l'international et aujourd'hui où ça se
joue pas à 5000 euros mais ça se joue à
deux cent millions 300 millions de
pertes et nous devons être à côté c'est
juste indispensable de nécessaire le coq
il en coûte du président de la
république ne va pas assez loin et n'a
pas cédé 4 milliards soit 1 point la
montagne non mais c'est on est là on on
sort effectivement d'une économie et d
qui était nécessaire d'avoir et moi je
n'ai encore vu bruno le maire cette
semaine et je lui dis de qualité des
rapports d'ailleurs que nous avons eues
à bercy pour travailler avec ses
services son cabinet pour trouver la
bonne définition nous sommes toujours
nous inscrit non pas en doublon aux
compétitions mais là où il y avait
nécessité dans les dispositifs d'état
devenir les compléter ça a été notre
stratégie plutôt que de se faire
concurrence ou de superposer les
dispositifs venant se compléter se
renforçait les uns les autres
donc ça c'est fait
mais le maintenant les entreprises vont
devoir petit à petit rembourser les
banques pourront se manifester auprès
d'eux pour rappeler à un moment donné
les traites d'emprunt enfin on va
rentrer dans le dur on vous sent inquiet
pour cette économie les deux fleurons
qui risque de disparaître tout à l'heure
vous pensez à quoi jusqu'à maintenant on
sait des dossiers que nous traitons au
quotidien mais ce sont de belles
entreprises régionales nombreux
touristes
il y en a une petite dizaine vingtaine
qui nous causent souci est que nous
accompagnons vraiment de manière très
proche mais c'est souvent un petit mail
de soutien en disant ok la solution
n'est pas encore là mais on pense à vous
et vous accompagne
on est vraiment avec et c'est ça aussi
porter un territoire c'est le faire dans
la proximité dans la connaissance
parfois de de l'expression douloureuse
de ses chefs d'entreprise qui ne voient
pas d'issue et de ligne d'arrivée et m
c'est petit à petit d'arriver à tracer
cette ligne avec eux est ce que le
dispositif régional parce que vous avez
fait beaucoup d'ennemis gros coup sur la
table mais ce qu'il est suffisamment
lisible et des patrons de très petites
entreprises quasiment des
auto-entrepreneurs qui disent bas on a
quand même du mal quand même de s'y
retrouver et de savoir à quoi on a droit
ou pas c'est vrai c'est vrai que c'est
compliqué parce que les dispositifs sont
nombreux ils ont été très rapides mais
c'est pour ça qu'on a travaillé vous le
savez en lié avec les chambres de
métiers chambre d'agriculture les cci
qu'il faut un boulot absolument
fantastique de proximité de terrain
sap a été à nous par exemple de gérer le
lien avec les commerçants au moment du
deuxième confinement on a confié cela
effectivement à chambre des métiers ou à
la cci dont c'est le rôle premier
d'accompagnement de modernisation de
numérisation c'est pas à nous de le
faire et je pense que c'est à la fois ce
que nous avons appris à mener et vous le
savez dans le business act donc c'est le
plan de relance régional qui étaient
mises en place pendant confinement à les
puissants personnes qui ont réfléchi
finalement à ce qui semblait prioritaire
à leurs yeux et qui nous a obligés à
finalement réaligner
politique est tel que nous imaginions en
fonction de leurs besoins et de leurs
expressions et surtout ce partenariat
on a fait un peu équipe de france du
grand est c'est à dire que dans cette
difficulté les coudes sont resserrés les
gens ont oublié peut-être un peu des
vaines querelles parfois politiques
parfois économique pour se dire
l'objectif c'est qu'on s'en sorte et on
va revenir longuement sur ces questions
régionales genre terme et elle pour
finir sur l'actualité nationale et ce
plan de relance au niveau national
philippe s qui va suffire à limiter la
casse économique comme il y aura des
restaurants on rentre maintenant on se
disait finalement la toussaint qui vient
de passer à l'être un peu la première le
premier la première zone un peu
difficile un peu compliqué d huile
deuxième confinement il ya eu un nouveau
plan de relance finalement numéro 2 donc
c'est à limiter la casse là on arrive à
la date anniversaire de l'arrivée du
coronavirus surtout chez nous d'ailleurs
cette fin février et donc attention il
faut être vigilant il faut être vision
justement dans cette sortie de crise il
faut pas qu'elle soit brutale
il faut pas que les banques viennent
demander lors du il faut pas que les
tapis et nous demander son dû je crois
que ça en tout cas bruno le maire l'a
largement compris c'est la seule à la la
sortie en douceur de pge
l'accompagnement comment est-ce qu'on
est face à sa dette comme en sport on
rentre dans les bilans des entreprises
nous qui sommes force publique de
manière discrète mais justement de
manière à pouvoir leur redonner la
liquidité redonner des perspectives le
monde de la culture et du cinéma quand
nous créons aujourd'hui une société
publique qui peut faire du lease back
donc racheté les murs de ces
propriétaires indépendants pour leur
confier dans dix quinze ans avec un
remboursement échelonné finalement de
cette prise en charge
c'est ce que nous faisons donc c'est un
travail sur des outils qui permettent
dans la durée de sortir doucement mais
sereinement du pg
le prêt est garanti par l'état il faudra
effacer une partie de cette dette pour
aider les entrepreneurs à repartir
c'est petit à petit ce qui se dessine à
travers les prêts participatifs à
travers éventuellement nous avons nous
essayé de mettre en place des
obligations convertibles enfin tous ces
mécanismes là sont en train d'être
étudiés c'est ce que je disais dans ces
nouveaux mécanismes ça ne concernera
peut-être pas les toutes petites
entreprises qui devront bénéficier
d'autres d'autre manière d'alléger cette
dette mais je pense que d'une manière ou
d'une autre oui il faudra peut-être un
moment donné pour certains ou bien
effacer effect et effacer cette charge
et sur le direct il faut finir là-dessus
pour être clair jean retenir ça veut
dire que quand on lisait du samedi on
espère que 2021 marquera la fin de la
crise sanitaire et donc la fin du quoi
qu'il en coûte vous dit
comme quoi qu'il en coûte il doit se
prolonger au delà de la crise sanitaire
donc c'est quoi qu'il en coûte c'est une
responsabilité collective avant de
laisser bien le gouvernement le 10 mai à
mort donnée c'est nous qui assumons
collectivement c'est nous les
contribuables c'est nous les français il
faudra remettre sur le tapis la réforme
des retraites aujourd'hui clairement est
ce que c'est un gros mot de dire qu'il
faudra bosser plus à eau au vu de cette
crise
on devra travailler plus on devra
remettre sur la table pour moi un
nouveau pacte social sur la santé sur la
retraite sur le travail
on ne peut pas aujourd'hui considéré que
la manière dont nous fonctionnions
jusqu'à l'an dernier permettra de passer
simplement bien les centaines de
milliards qui auront été mis dans cette
crise en chemin il faudra à un moment
donné qu ensemble nous arrivions à nous
relancer
franchement les gens ordinaires remettre
sur la table la aujourd'hui retraite
aujourd'hui est-ce que ça a mal agi je
me suis peut-être mal fait comprendre
jeudi il faudra pas aujourd'hui c'est
pour un prochain entraîneur oui c'est
pour un prochain quinquennat mais je
pense quand j'ai dit il faudra en
responsabilité collectivement il faut
que les français assument ensemble ce
que nous venons de traverser
c'est pas le moment je suis d'accord
avec vous aujourd'hui c'est les
solutions liées à la crise et je pense
que mais ça peut faire un beau projet
pour un futur président allez on va
parler de l'actualité régionale
justement là on commençait manière
avec vous sur la collectivité antennes
d'alsace oui sans surprise jean rottner
vous vous y attendez sans doute je vais
vous parler de jean castex qui est venu
à colmar le 23 janvier dernier qui a
fait une sortie remarquée par vous par
beaucoup de monde à propos de la loi
notre et de son peu de goût des grandes
régions
il crée en 2015 il a expliqué en deux
mots qui il n'avait jamais été convaincu
par leur pertinence et leur légitimité
historique
évidemment tout le monde a compris qu'il
visait en particulier le grand test vous
avez assez vite critiqué un coup
politique
vous restez sur cette analyse clairement
et visez pas le grand ainsi visé jean
rottner
il avait fait un déplacement politique
parce qu'il n'a pas apprécié ma phrase
et il ne m'en faire placer sur la crise
intérieure
tout simplement il est venu faire un
coup politique excusez moi mais c'est
aussi simple que ça c'est aussi simple
que vous êtes senti personnellement visé
par cette fois bien sûr tout est
organisé pour que je sois pleinement
visé personnellement par cette attaque
c'est assez amusant parce que quelques
minutes après dans la salle avec les
parlementaires les autres élus ils
louaient par exemple le fait régional
dans la délégation de compétences sur
les routes nationales qui pour lui ne
pouvait pas être départementale mais ne
pouvait être que régionale
et d'ailleurs ça résultait d'un
entretien qu on avait eu aussi l'un avec
l'autre
quelques il y à il ya quelques mois oui
c'est effectivement dans la loi-cadre
défigurera la compétence route nationale
qui pourra être déléguées à l'échelle
régionale philippe sur la trentaine sur
la lorraine ces situations vous pouvez
laisser un engagement là dessus je suis
un repreneur d'une situation comme ça
donc pour revenir à votre question oui
il est venu faire un déplacement
politique et moi je le regrette je le
regrette parce qu'il a rallumé des feux
qui petit à petit c'était niais qui
permettait au niveau de la région et au
niveau de l'alsace d'aller de l'avant de
travailler ensemble
j'étais un peu gêné pour sa ministre
jacqueline gourault qui est à ses côtés
je crois avait beaucoup donné qui a été
obligé d'ailleurs de rectifier ou de
réaligner ses propos à l'assemblée
nationale et au sénat
c'est un peu dérangeant et je pense que
c'est pas du niveau d'un premier
ministre mais vous même jean rottner
avait déjà été critique à l'égard des
grandes régions dont par le passé alors
aujourd'hui vous en est devenu président
région de rentrer en 2014 vous aviez
lancé une pétition contre cette thèse
emmanuel je crois que je les dis
d'ailleurs devant mon hémicycle la
semaine dernière j'ai dit que dans
l'hémicycle régional
je pense qu'il ya peu de personnes qui
étaient enthousiastes à la réforme de la
loi notre et à la création de ces
entités
avant de donner nous sommes républicains
la loi est votée par le parlement bien
on s'y engage on défend son territoire
on cherche à promouvoir son économie à
développer l'environnement à être actif
dans un cadre qui est un cadre
république et moi je ne conteste pas la
loi la loi elle s'applique et avant de
donner aussi un peuple est plus
enthousiaste comme argument je respecte
la loi
ça sent bon le printemps nous allons non
non non je reste mais c'est important de
le dire parce qu'une remise en
continuelle de la loi certains dans deux
mondes assemblée le font de manière
régulière
on les a vus on les a vus on les entend
vous voyez de
ils sont en à droite à mon extrême
droite mais on avait précédé gens que je
combattrai toujours toujours parce qu'il
entraîne la suspicion il entraîne
probablement une forme de désordre et
contrairement à ce qu'ils prétendent
être un méchant et ça ça me direct
ensuite je me suis je crois largement
intégrées dans ce travail régional j
essaie d'y impulser de l'equilibre de
l'équité un regard égal sur tous les
territoires est une forme de promotion
aujourd'hui je vais vous dire même pas
du grand test net de l'est de la france
parce que l'est de la france voir gagner
par rapport à l'ouest aujourd'hui nos
compétences nos usines
notre savoir faire au niveau national
bien il est à toulouse à rennes à nantes
à bordeaux et il n'est plus chez nous il
n'est plus chez nous et donc qu'on doit
être dans une phase de reconquête et
cette phase de reconquête aujourd'hui
c'est faire de la politique pour sa
territoire pas de rentrer dans le veine
querelles ou de vaines rente de
situation qui permette un moment de
grâce à certains d'exister par un
discours aujourd'hui genre clair vous
parle vous parler d' équilibre est ce
que vous comprenez vous pouvez parfois
perçu comme un équilibriste sur une
ligne de crête
selon le côté des vosges est ce qu'au
fond quand même la collectivité
européenne d'alsace c'est quand même pas
le début du détricotage du grand est est
deuxième question de la foulée s confond
vous même
qu'est ce qu'on fait nous mêmes vous ne
rêvez pas de revenir aux régions
historiques
non non parce que je vois aujourd'hui la
force la pertinence l'efficacité
l'efficacité économique la puissance
transfrontalière la capacité
effectivement des dans un rapport de
force par rapport au bade-wurtemberg des
choses qui n'existaient pas avant et
ensuite par rapport à votre première
question pas pour me mettre des lauriers
mais quand vous avez vu votre seul le
sondage de votre de vos confrères des
échos 75 74 % d' indice de satisfaction
c'est qui est peut-être quand même vous
êtes l'asie région le plus apprécié
d'applis on y accueille peut-être des
choses qui se passent il ya quand même
peut-être un travail reconnu pas
forcément le mien celui d'une équipe
celui d'une administration et ce qui est
insupportable d'ailleurs pour finir
là-dessus sur les critiques du premier
ministre ce qui remet en cause le
travail de 7500 personnes
7500 collaborateurs qui construisent qui
sont aujourd'hui engagés dans ce travail
et régionales une petite phrase est ce
que j'ai dit a balayé tout ce travail de
cinq ans c'est un supporter on va
continuer à parler est ce que vous dit
le premier ministre il a commis une
faute un premier ministre n'a pas dire
car je pense que c'est une erreur
politique c'est une heure planète foot
c'est une erreur politique ça fait
partie de la vie politique il faut
savoir encaisser
j'aurais pu être absent parce que je
sais mais je savais grosso modo qui
venait pour moi je suis allé sur le ring
j'y suis allé j'ai encaissé j'ai réagi
je crois dignement honnêtement avec mes
convictions je n'ai pas fait de
politique politicienne
mais j'ai agi comme il se devait de
réagir maintenant c'est la juste ça
s'est arrêté là là là la polémique
frédéric guéry dans la foulée sur notre
antenne d'ailleurs à réagir aux propos
de jean castex vous l'avez forcément
entendu il a appelé au démembrement la
région quand est ce que vous avez pensé
vous savez l'ex n est jamais bon et je
pense que aujourd'hui si on parle de la
cea et de frédéric que je vois
d'ailleurs la semaine prochaine on a une
séance de travail ensemble en commun
dont vous voyez les ponts ne sont pas
rompus
j'ai vendu un titre qui disait que nous
étions c'était mon mon meilleur mon
meilleur ennemi c'est pas du tout le cas
moi je ne me situe pas là dedans mais
aujourd'hui j'ai une certitude sur la
cee
c'est que elle doit démontrer les élus
de ceux là doivent démontrer leur
efficacité non pas vis à vis du grand
est ce le sujet n'est pas là c'est mes
vieilleries des alsaciens et leur projet
politique ne doit pas servir un projet
politiciens d'un projet d'efficacité
pour tous les alsaciens au quotidien ils
sont attendus au dessus ils sont
attendus à dessus par leurs partenaires
notre côté des vosges on va mais si l'on
fait un projet politicien lui frédéric
et aux béjaouis là-dessus une forme d'
utilisation politicienne par certains
oui c'est clair que cette petite phrase
elle n'était pas anodine mais elle n'est
pas nouvelle non plus dans la bouche de
frédéric c'est un coup là aussi pardon
c'est un coup politique là aussi de
parler de des mouvements
oui mais je crois que vous savez le
souffle est tombée est-ce que vous ne
doutez pas des évolutions dans la loi
cadre d justement non aussi vous
attendez vous appelez de vos espoirs et
loi cadre des surnoms jeu les
autorisations des concentrations je vis
la loi quête d puisque jacqueline
gourault elle fait vous savez le tour de
france un peu des activités donc elle
nous a envoyé le texte préparatoire
s'est pas texter révolutionnaire mais
c'est un texte qui laisse la possibilité
à chacun d'avancer de progresser et en
tout cas moi je le ferai avec les autres
départements je rappelle à l'échelle de
la région qui l'a déjà département qui
dans une forme de différenciation bien
plus avancé et aboutie que l'alsace ces
départements des ardennes
ça s'appelle le paternel et dans le
pacte ardennes on a contractualisé état
collectivités partenaires pour avancer
plus rapidement différemment et on n'a
pas eu besoin de loi pour le faire ça
s'est fait sur des projets sur des
actions extrêmement que extrêmement
concrètes et quand je vois aujourd'hui
la relocalisation d'un industriel du
vélo qui se localise dans les ardennes
c'est aussi le fruit de cette confiance
qu'on a réussi à créer au niveau de ce
département avec parfois des crédits
fléchés spécifique réfléchi et décidé au
niveau de la région et justement on va
aller pas très loin du département des
ardennes on va aller dans l'ancienne
région champagne ardenne à troyes dans
l'aube on va écouter damiao redois
rédacteur en chef adjoint de canal 32 il
est donc une question à vous poser deux
questions en une
autour de l'avenir de la région grand
est vue de l'aube le grand test
justement a beaucoup fait un peu de
temps ne craignez-vous pas que les
derniers événements liés à la création
de la nouvelle collectivité alsacienne
ne vienne compliquer les choses et puis
dans un deuxième temps les sénateurs de
la partie ouest de la rue
on répète que la champagne a parfois
peur d'être l'oublier de cette grande
région qu'il y en a en fait que pour les
alsaciens que leur dire pour les
rassurer et va très bien je vais
commencer par la deuxième
j'entends souvent effectivement une
bouche de philippe rivet en face de moi
aussi question qui interroge encore une
fois mon rôle est un rôle
effectivement non pas d'équilibriste
mais d' équilibre entre tous les
territoires de la région
il appartient aussi aux sénateurs aux
parlementaires aux élus de l'aube vient
d'être des acteurs - je leur dis souvent
quand je suis seul j'ai besoin de vous
n'attendez pas tous de la région
nous avons besoin de travailler ensemble
je réunis tous les parlementaires
mensuellement à paris pour leur montrer
expliquer ce que font ce que fait la
région
ils peuvent s'en saisir ils peuvent me
saisir j'ai vu d'ailleurs une nouvelle
sénatrice de l'homme il y a quinze jours
sur des projets extrêmement concret qui
permettent de faire 2 3 d'ailleurs un
des lieux peut être privilégiée de la
cyberdéfense dans ce pays nous avons des
projets je rappelle que mon prédécesseur
sur la ligne 4 paris troyes belfort
mulhouse a pris des initiatives
extrêmement forte que qui se met fac qui
ont été mises en oeuvre
l'ecri fication la prise en
responsabilité de cette ligne le
développement de nouveaux matériels donc
l'homme n'est pas oublié et nous
continuons fortement à investir dans ce
sur ce territoire nous continuerons
d'ailleurs avec un certain nombre
peut-être de projets industriels
extrêmement lourd ce math antifa des
situations comme celle du coq sportif de
petits bateaux wind cdac d'actualité
pour moi qui me nourrissent et qu'ils
nourrissent mon action publique et j'ai
besoin de la champagne aujourd'hui
j'étais avec les viticulteurs le
champagne la semaine dernière pour faire
pour prendre acte de leur bilan et à -18
% de chiffre d'affaires moi j'aurais
signé il ya un peu un peu moins d'un an
sur 1 1
un résultat de ce type là parce que
c'était catastrophique au début mais
s'en sont tirés on les a accompagnés on
accompagne aujourd'hui leur transition
vers un vignoble bas carbone et sans
pesticides tout cela c'est une attention
tous les jours vous voyez j'ai pas de
notes
je ne m'attendais pas à cette réunion
mais ça vous montre que ces sujets c'est
mes sujets du quotidien je les connais
par coeur
quand je connais par coeur les sujets de
la lorraine où les sujets de l'alsace
c'est juste mon quotidien et je tiens à
être sur le terrain j'étais du côté de
nancy encore hier pour comprendre pour
voir pour entendre malgré ce masque
malgré la distanciation rien ne m'est
pas sera en tout cas du terrain c'est
c'est bon c'est mon plaisir d'être là
aussi au contact des autres loeb loeb
n'est pas oubliée disiez-vous l'instant
le reste de la champagne non plus on
vous on vous croit volontiers mais vous
voyez bien que de leur point de vue il y
en a un peu trop pour l'alsace en ce
moment ils entendent que la sava à plein
nez avec anne déjà de nouvelles
compétences à la faveur peut-être de la
loi cadre des ou d'une manière ou d'une
autre
frédéric bierry par exemple presse
réclamait déjà la compétence santé il ya
quelques jours
oui mais c'est pas parce qu'on augmente
le volume que la raison moi la raison
c'est la loi le baromètre c'est la loi
mais il attendait on attendait que dit
la loi il atteint devait leur espace al
wasat ce qu'est ce qu'elle dit
contrairement à ce que j'entends
beaucoup sur les compétences la loi z
aucune compétence supplémentaire aux
départements d'alsace
ce n'est pas une compétence routière
elle re précise avoir un impact
important sur le tracé lorraine moi ça
ne me dérange pas quand il y aura
l'expérience alsacienne je revendique à
l'échelle régionale
une différenciation du même type qui
pourra arranger tout le monde y compris
les acières d'ailleurs parce que une
taxe une taxe carbone ou routière à
l'échelle des êtres se sera pas avant
cinq ou six ans c'est vraiment que faire
la région si la cea décide de d'avoir
recours à cette année la mairie qu'il
pleuvra la région pour rééquilibrer les
flux philippe rivet s'est fixé par la
loi s'est décidée par la loi c'est une
la seule compétence supplémentaire du
département d'alsace donc ce serait
affaires de l'état à côté
donc si le faire effectivement entre
l'état et ce département à côté de cela
moi je milite et nous sommes en train de
travailler pour cela pour avoir une
compétence encore plus large sur la les
routes et la loi 4d nous permet de la
voie d une bannière a justement
équilibré à être au chevet aujourd'hui
de cette lorraine qui n'a jamais réussi
à décider
depuis trente ans de ces axes majeurs et
de ses capacités d'avoir une
intermodalité beaucoup plus poussée de
deux secteurs comme la rn4 aujourd'hui
qui est un secteur qu'il faut largement
poussée de développer en face on vous
parlait d'intermodalité une série
d'accords pour une gare d'interconnexion
qui n'est jamais vu le jour en mai j'ai
toujours dit que dans le cadre
d'ailleurs du grenelle des mobilités
c'est un sujet qu'il fallait reposer sur
la table et moi ces sujets là ne font
pas peur et il faut abandonner que l'on
soit conséquent mais comme réfléchissent
pas à 5 ans et qu'on réfléchisse à 30 ou
40 ans et justement puisqu'on est dans
les interrégionaux va continuer
puisqu'on parle de transport on va
continuer avec vous un philippin a parlé
de ses transports aménagement du
territoire
oui justement vous avez pris nouveau
chez votre budget enfin qui est devenu à
s'effacer vert si on a compris et
dernière session du conseil régional et
notamment la mobilité verte puisque vous
les renforcée des accès aux ter ont
parlé de véhicules électriques mais je
vais m'intéresser aux au ter vous
demander si les petites lignes que vous
souhaitez ouvrir pour vraiment ouvrir
grâce au choix de la concurrence
ferroviaire que vous avez anticipé parce
que franchement à un opérateur privé va
s'intéresser une petite ligne il ya
quelques dizaines de passagers par jour
alors quelques quelques nouvelles déjà
de ces deux ouvertures la concurrence
sur les deux lignes que nous avons
ouverte
nous arrivons d'ailleurs au troisième
lot qui est le lot transfrontalier qui
va bientôt là aussi rentrer dans une
démarche d'ouverture à la concurrence
nous avons sur chacun des deux premiers
lots 4 propositions
quatre propositions c'est intéressant ça
montre justement que notre démarche bien
elles attirent elles attirent justement
ces opérateurs qui dans le paysage
français vont devoir compter à côté de
la sncf
ça veut dire aussi que naulleau soit
adapté pourquoi parce que généralement
sur ce genre de stratégie on a un voire
deux candidats là on en a quatre
donc on va pouvoir faire jouer
effectivement la concurrence et la
négociation
je trouve ça assez intéressant et moi je
considère que c'est pas parce qu' une
petite ligne que l'on rouvre à 1000
passagers
à certains moments que elle est inutile
je pense qu'elle construise territoire
et qu'il faut changer de paradigme
mais là aussi ça soit ont travaillé sur
le temps long pas sur l'instantané pas
sur les fed annonce mais aujourd'hui
enferré si nous ne prenions pas la
responsabilité qui est la nôtre
aujourd'hui
ça veut dire que des lignes comme
strasbourg sarreguemines strasbourg
lauterbourg strasbourg wissembourg
fermerait fermerait parce que elles sont
dans un tel état que nous ne pourrions
plus faire rouler dans les deux ans qui
viennent des trains sur ces voies
ferrées ça veut dire que epinal
saint-dié serait définitivement
ça veut dire que epinal nancy ne
pourraient plus fonctionner nous prenons
nos responsabilités nous investissons et
je peux vous le dire
l'année la plus difficile va être 2024
nous aurons à la fois un investissement
sur le matériel est à la fois
investissements sur les faits réels
seront des investissements extrêmement
lourd mais nous le faisons pas pour nous
je serai plus là mais parce que c'est ma
responsabilité aujourd'hui bien d'aller
non pas vers ce green washing mais vers
cette nécessité aujourd'hui de
développer à l'échelle de notre région
un transport ferré moderne cohérent à
bas coût pour l'usager et qu'ils
puissent le pousser à quitter sa voiture
et utiliser le train voilà la stratégie
nous le faisons et j'espère et ça a été
annoncé lors de la dernière plénière
nous arriverons à quelque chose de très
simple si c'est à dire le demi tarif
pour tout le monde sur le transport
interurbain que ce soit car où que ce
soit des verts au delà du soutien au
transport ferroviaire donc que vous
venez d'évoquer vous parlez vous aimez
parler de budget vert à propos du budget
primitif que la région grand test vient
d'adopter
c'est un slogan alors nous en nous avait
un peu expliqué mais au delà des
transports en quoi ce budget est vert
c'est déjà une démarche interne c'est à
dire que l'ensemble des élus et
de mes services doivent aujourd'hui se
poser la question quand ils prennent une
décision si cette décision est
effectivement en cohérence avec la
stratégie verte finalement de la
préservation de la planète qui est celle
de la région celle du gouvernement celle
de l'europe
c'est aussi simple que ça aujourd'hui ça
nous amène même dans nos investissements
industriels par exemple à nous poser
cette question faut-il soutenez un
industriel qui veut venir sur notre
territoire investir 200 millions d'euros
par exemple pour produire de l'hydrogène
verte de l'urgence grise par exemple ou
ne faut-il pas parce que justement ne
produit pas du danger en garde
moi je suis pour la deuxième solution je
suis pour la deuxième solution parce que
c'est une transformation d'état d'esprit
deuxième transformation d'état d'esprit
que l'on constate le seul critère alors
pardon l'emploi n'est pas le seul
traitement c'est pas c'est plus le
critère pourquoi parce que justement
c'est la deuxième option on constate
aujourd'hui une forme de responsabilité
sociale et environnementale de nos
industriels qui sont sur notre
territoire ou qui veulent s'y installer
et qui est de dire c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'industrie 5.0 c'est-à-dire
coquet 2.0 la modernisation des chaînes
de production s'y ajoutent aujourd'hui
justement l'environnement et la
responsabilité sociale d'avoir un cadre
de travail beaucoup plus adéquat
beaucoup plus réfléchie c'est hyper
important pourquoi parce que c'est une
plus value supplémentaire je pense sur
des marchés sur la capacité d'être dans
la promotion la préservation de la
planète et d'avoir un facteur
différenciant et ses créateurs de valeur
ses créateurs d'emplois ces créateurs de
formation ses créateurs là aussi d'une
image nouvelle je parlais de l'est de la
france toute heure c'est ça c'est
comment est-ce que notre image
d'industrie d'industrie lourde et bien
est en capacité de se transformer petit
à petit pour être celle d'une industrie
moderne qui reste lourde qui reste
productive et qui est adapté aujourd'hui
à la pression sociale de l'ours ans qui
s'est effectivement de vivre dans un
cadre différent sion on va parler du
dossier way est ce que vous avez mise en
oeuvre des critères environnementaux
pour accélérer l'implantation louis
deuxième question et ouais est-ce que
vous avez des engagements suffisamment
fort pour assurer les recrutements et
selon une certaine pérennité
si je vous pose cette question sécu des
expériences malheureuses les années 2000
en lorraine est ce qu'on a appelé les
usines tournevis c'était un petit tour
et puis s'en vont bien sûr je comprends
cette question et je veux dire qu'elle
m'a hanté pendant tout le dossier
elle monte pendant tout le dossier est
pour ça que nous n'avons progressé déjà
qu'avec l'accord de l'elysée et du plus
haut niveau de l'elysée
si j'avais eu un logo n'aurions pas
continuer négociations et donc tous ces
faits entre business france l'élysée la
région les acteurs locaux la dia
beaucoup travaillé sur ce sujet vous le
savez nous avons été choisis
grosso modo sur une cinquantaine de
sites qu'as tu étais sûr sur la région
autour de strasbourg parce que c'était
la volonté de wade dès le départ d'être
autour de strasbourg dans une position
frontalière extrêmement intéressante
parce que leur usine de produire certes
pour la france mais surtout pour lui
pour l'europe et dans ce cadre là dès le
départ et moi dès la première réunion
s'était effectivement des conditions
environnementales des conditions de
présence dans la formation dans la
progression là aussi l'accompagnement
l'intégration dans un écosystème local
moi qui me semble fondamental a dit van
as dans une chaîne également de sous
traitance qui ne soit pas une chemise
c'est dans ce mondial mais au minimum
européenne voire française au maximum
tout cela c'est encore dans les
discussions que nous avons qui sont en
cours et qui conditionneront aussi notre
soutien à l'implantation vous nous
disiez à l'instant le l'emploi n'est pas
le seul critère huawei à terme devrait
en créer 300 peut-être même 500 mhz et
donc si ça n'est pas le seul critère est
ce que dans les raisons d'un éventuel no
go comme vous disiez aussi il n'ya pas
le cv un peu sulfureux de cette
entreprise je rappelle que huawei eux
mêmes le leader mondial de la
reconnaissance faciale de la
vidéosurveillance et on sait le sort
réservé en chine
howie bourse par exemple la laine de la
technologie oui bien sûr mais là aussi
encore une fois c'est un travail que
nous avons fait avec les plus hautes
autorités de l'état parce que cette
implantation commencé à se décider à se
profiler au moment de la crise majeure
entre la chine et les états unis
il y avait des incertitudes politiques
il y avait des enjeux peut être qui me
dépassait et je les accepte largement et
encore une fois j'aurais accepté prises
et me disent non n'y va pas parce que
parce que parce que ça n'a pas été le
cas
oui il y à un questionnement
je rappelle que ce qui est produit ici
ce sont aujourd'hui des modules pour la
4g et de la salle g qui se développe
quand même partout il ya des choix
industriels qui appartiennent aux
fournisseurs d'accès aujourd'hui à la
salle g qui se font avec ou sans
ouailles
on est dans une logique industrielle et
c'est pas parce qu'il ya une logique
industrielle c'est pas parce qu'il a
créé son l'emploi qu'on ne peut pas être
exigeant et qu'aujourd'hui cette
exigence c'est pas simplement tu me crée
de l'emploi pendant dix ans et ensuite
qu'il retire pas elle est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure c'est qu'elle est
différente aujourd'hui on met sur la
table effectivement des critères
environnementaux
on met des critères de durée on met des
critères d'intégration dans l'écosystème
on met du critère là aussi respectueux
du territoire qu'un industriel doit
contribuer à développer
on va parler du parlement repères dans
quelques instants avec les manuels et
fip est une question sur un autre
dossier c'est le dossier stocamine
barbara pompili annoncé que les 42 mille
tonnes de déchets enfouis dans les
anciennes mines de potasse d'alsace ne
seraient pas remontés en compensation
elle s'est engagée à lancer un programme
de protection de la nappe phréatique de
50 millions est ce que vous comprenez la
décision de la ministre
non non parce que si nous vaut une
décision très verticale alors il ya une
décision on peut au moins saluer le fait
qu'une décision et qu'on sache sur quel
pied danser
pour une fois c'est plutôt pas mal après
c'est un dossier qui moi justement quand
je vous parlais de perspectives à 30 ou
50 ans ça c'est aussi là ils doivent
plus exister
on doit prendre nos responsabilités on
doit savoir comment les traiter on doit
savoir envisager le pire
être en capacité à un moment donné 2 2
d'avoir une réversibilité de le traiter
aujourd'hui on a trop attendu expertise
contre expertise
alors ma propre et lisse et devrait
prendre une décision moi j'étais plutôt
pour ce qu'on appelle le scénario si ce
qui permettait au moins d'extraire au
delà du symbole d'un certain nombre de
ces matières la ministre en a décidé
autrement c'est plié genre tenace et en
anglais vous espérez la faire revenir
sur cette décision
je pense que enfin le premier ministre
l'a aussi à colmar a réaffirmé son
soutien à cette décision
donc je pense que c'est plié mais ça ne
nous empêche pas et ça ne m'empêche pas
de réagir sur ce dossier et de le
regretter de regretter vraiment moi je
ne souhaite plus qu'aujourd'hui en face
d'un positif de cette manière là et
qu'on prenne de décision publique de
cette manière là enfin il faut le faire
de manière responsable et encore une
fois le sens et la beauté de l'action
publique et ne s'exerce que si on a
cette réalité à la fois de l'immédiateté
et ses perspectives qui donne du sens
aux choses que l'on fait et surtout que
l'on laisse derrière soi un mot sans
parlement européen oui a effectivement
frédéric guéry encore lui et bruyamment
monté au créneau récemment en faisant
même le voyage de bruxelles pour prendre
la défense du siège strasbourgeois du
parlement européen qu'ils estiment
menacée effectivement toute l'année
dernière les députés ont siégé ailleurs
qu'à bruxelles à strasbourg raconte à
bruxelles justement que york à bruxelles
aussi oui mais qu'en dites-vous vous sur
ce dossier il faut jouer ensemble il
faut travailler ensemble ensemble est là
aussi
moi je suis très heureux d'avoir le
soutien sur ce dossier a simplement des
alsaciens mais des parlementaires
de l'ensemble de la région des
parlementaires français il faut aller
beaucoup plus large et voir beaucoup
plus large que simplement un problème
strasbourgeois ou un problème alsacien
c'est important pour nous alsaciens
effectivement c'est important pour la
région c'est la capitale régionale
c'est important pour l'europe que l'on
respecte là aussi des traités mais il
faut peut-être que nous envisagions et
c'est ce que nous essayons terres
d'entraînement de faire un pas de côté
et de voir ce dossier aujourd'hui de le
traiter de manière différente pas comme
il se traite depuis 30 ans comme une
forme de rente de situation et qu'on
parte à la conquête et qu'on ait envie
plus que jamais de voir à strasbourg se
développer un rôle peut-être particulier
celui du parlement celui des
institutions
il ya peut-être une stratégie commune à
avoir avec tout son bord qui n'est pas
très loin même avoir à une bruxelles je
vous rappelle que je préside aujourd'hui
une structure qui s'appelle la grande
région qui rassemble la vallonie le
luxembourg la sarre la rhénanie
palatinat et grant est sauf l'alsace ou
qui est dans nos rangs supérieurs qui
dans une autre institution
transfrontalière je le dis pas c'est
compliqué à suivre quand même oui non
mais attendez je le dis parce que dans
la grande région
qu'est ce qui se passe en à strasbourg
on à luxembourg et même si bruxelles et
a un statut particulier est très proche
de la vallonie ayant cette intelligence
stratégique justement pour les alsaciens
de se dire la structure les relais
proposait justement à mes collègues qui
ont trouvé cette vision assez
intéressante
ziani ne défendront pas strasbourg ne
défendront pas luxembourg ne défendons
pas bosser mais y ont peut-être là aussi
un deal sur le rôle de chacun
il ya la technocratie qui est à
bruxelles il ya la capitale de la
démocratie d'un certain nombre de
valeurs à strasbourg et il ya une
capitale très administrative financière
alexandre mais ce qu'on pensait que
c'était horrible par l'opinion là dessus
c'est ce que vous pensez emporté sans
doute l'opinion à sienne mes opinions
lorraine et champardennais zh qui
s'interrogent sur le coût de
fonctionnement de
en dix ans il y à strasbourg et à
bruxelles et à luxembourg comment la
convaincre mais mais je crois justement
en différenciant un peu le rôle de
chacun là on a l'impression c'est aussi
une méconnaissance de ces institutions
moi je rappelle qu'à strasbourg on a
quand même encore open de droits de
l'homme on a quand même des institutions
extrêmement fortes liées justement à ces
valeurs et ces valeurs qui illustre
totalement ce qu'est l'europe
aujourd'hui et qu'il faut défendre on
peut être plus que jamais avec des pays
qui frise quand même
aussi certaines valeurs qui ne sont pas
les valeurs de notre république
française
donc il faut les rappeler et strasbourg
je pense peut être justement ça ça peut
être largement compris oui il y a un
projet politique à défendre les valeurs
de schumann les les valeurs de qui sont
pas celles aura quand même fac à passer
européen chaud et donc je crois que ça
nous oui
les habitants du grand est les français
sont sensibles à ce sujet là moi je ne
veux pas aller en guerre contre
bruxelles je veux défendre un vrai
projet on a bien on a bien compris il
nous reste cinq minutes on va parler des
régionales à philippe des régionales est
ce que vous êtes déjà candidat parce
qu'on sait pas seul comprend une
monsieur river c'est celle de la
vaccination
oui c'est celle où dix longtemps mais
j'entends bien ça change sinon c'est ce
qu'il faudra vous observez président et
les sessions on comprend aujourd'hui que
votre principal adversaire c'est le
rabbin le rassemblement national
davantage que la gauche ou davantage que
les écologistes qui nous ont un peu
poussé à grimaud chez votre budget là
disent les mauvaises langues mais façon
quelle est votre dernière pour vous de
là dessus quel est votre adversaire est
ce que un durcissement des finalement à
un duel entre jean rottner et l'extrême
droite pour les pour les prochaines
régionales
déjà faudrait que je sois candidat mais
l'extrême droite et mon adversaire à
votre décision est prise sur terre mon
adversaire est avant tout le front
national et les extrêmes quel qu'il soit
je le répète quand je vois aujourd'hui
la suspicion le mensonge le les débats
qui frise franchement c'est pas de la
politique ont fait entendu du bac à
sable
et ça ne lève pas et ça ne reconsidère
pas la politique et les solutions
simplistes à mener ou les analyses
simplistes a mené par ces gens là pour
moi ne peuvent pas être celle qui a
abandonné seront à la tête soit d'une
région soit
de la nation c'est juste impossible donc
mon combat ma responsabilité sera
toujours effectivement de lutter contre
l'extrême droite
c'est clair net et précis est-ce qu'il
faut que ces régionales se tiennent en
juin comme c'est pour l'instant prévu ou
est-ce que c'est conditionné à la
situation sanitaire le coup dit souvent
le dr possible dans les meilleures
conditions possibles pourquoi je dis ça
parce que alors on dit oui mais il faut
la respiration démocratique d'accord oui
il faut une responsable une
responsabilité et une responsable d'une
respiration démocratique il faut
renouveler ses instances il faut nous
donner aussi la possibilité d'agir
aujourd'hui on est pieds et poings liés
par messi c'est impossible en juin en
raison du co lead je vais finir par
simplement le fait que depuis le 1er
septembre on est en compte de campagne
on peut pas faire une nouvelle annonce
on est toujours avec cette peur au
dessus c'est enclume au 2e set
pardon
et donc il faut il faut effectivement
que cette respiration existe mais si
c'est une respiration qui n'est qu'une
app 9 10 % de participation en juin
parce qu'elles ont peur parce que on est
dans la logique de ce qu'on a pu
connaître aux municipales c'est pas
génial comme respiration non plus donc
ainsi on sait cela il va falloir faire
campagne
il va falloir renouveler ses campagnes
parce qu'elles vont pas être comme les
précédentes
et donc si il doit y avoir élections
effectivement il faut que ça se fasse
dans les meilleures conditions possibles
et c'est malheureusement le virus qui
fixe l'agenda et cépages juin ce sera
après la présidentielle or mais après ça
pose un problème constitutionnel
pas de trop pour les régions des
départements d'ailleurs qui sait quand
pour vous la bonne fenêtre pour moi
aujourd'hui ses joueurs et qui est la
meilleure de décider de la première la
première fenêtre c'est potentiellement
juin mais je crains que ce mois de juin
2 soit largement compromis par les
analyses scientifiques que l'on tente en
ce moment par la poussée des variants
une dernière question parce qu'on arrive
au bout de cette émission juste pendant
une heure vous avez très peu voire pas
du tout prononcé le nom d' emmanuel
macron quand vous en parlez vous parlez
de l'elysée quelles sont vos relations
aujourd'hui avec le président de la
république il est président de la
république sur président de région vous
avez macro compatibles ou pas ouais je
suis compatible je les dis avec des
présents la république parce que je suis
à république à la tête d'un exécutif
j'étais compatible que j'étais maire de
mulhouse même si le niveau de
responsabilité n'était pas le même avec
le précédent président de la république
je crois que côte
effectivement on est dans une démarche
républicaine on est en capacité de
travailler avec tout le monde veut pas
dire qu'on est en accord sur tout ça
veut pas dire qu'on partage tout ça veut
pas dire qu'on est dans la même lignée
ou filière de penser ça veut dire que
parfois il peut y avoir effectivement
comme ce qui s'est passé à colmar et
bien quelques quelques contestations et
quelques
moment un petit peu plus compliqué mais
claire clairement genre terre
aujourd'hui vous êtes dans l'opposition
aujourd'hui je suis la tête de ma région
et j'ai un projet j'ai un projet de
mandat et je construis et je ne suis pas
moins dans une opposition qui est une
opposition idéologique et j'essaie de
faire progresser et de faire se
rapprocher les territoires et l'état
c'est une de mes plus grandes vocation
et ce sera le mot de la fin avant de se
quitter on va bien sûr regardé les unes
de nos partenaires ils sont nombreux les
cinq journaux qui nous accompagnent dans
cette émission on commence par là une
des dernières nouvelles d'alsace et jean
castex qui est à la une des dna
aujourd'hui on ne change rien ou presque
c'est à la une à la une du républicain
lorrain ce sont les aides à domicile un
secteur en crise c'est la lune choisi ce
matin par le républicain lorrain autre
sujet à la une de vosges matin
agressions en série c'est le titre de
vosges matin après une violente
agression qui a eu lieu à vittel lundi
et qui ne s'avère ne pas être un cas
isolé et messieurs je vais vous laisser
parler de vos une à une de l'alsace
emmanuel c'est aussi jean castex
oui jean castex effectivement et puis on
revient aussi aujourd'hui en séquences
région sur la crise sanitaire encore
elle mais sous l'angle de des
contraintes qu'elle a posé aux nombreux
conseils municipaux qui ne pouvait plus
se tenir en physique est pareil en 10
secondes là philippe la une de l'est
républicain
la patrouille je crois que ce soit pas
être remis le français
il y aura donc groupe à de grandes
manifestations physiques de grands
rassemblements pour admirer patrouille
de france
mais nous a offert quand même un survol
de la région les passer au dessus de la
base de nancy au chai et voilà et c'est
sur ces mots qu'on reste quitté merci
beaucoup je retenais aussi la main
tout cas merci de vous poser en région
c'est extrêmement important pour nous
mais on est ravis on est ravi d'être là
merci beaucoup merci messieurs et merci
à toutes les équipes techniques et des
taux réels qui ont permis la réalisation
de cette émission vous êtes un très bon
week-end sur nos antennes
[Musique]